Okay. Uh, in Hosea 11, it says, "When
Israel was a youth, I loved him and out
of Egypt I called my son." How do I
explain this prophecy to someone? Um,
uh, because I think when I read in the
context, is it talking about Israel or
It is talking about Israel. It's talking
about the nation because it goes on to
say how Israel rebelled against him and
broke his heart and how God's heart is
turned within him with compassion and
says, "How can I give you up? I can't. I
love you too much even though I
discipline you." Okay. So when it says
and out of Egypt I called my son that
that specifically would it be a double
prophecy or is it like well I mean it's
not so much a double prophecy as it is
an indication that what Israel
experience the Messiah will experience.
I mentioned that in the past but I'm
going to show you what I mean. Okay. The
Old Testament has already prepared the
Jews that the
Messiah, his life will
recapitulate what happened to Israel so
that things that happened to Israel will
happen to him. I'm going to give you and
guys, I need you to listen to this. This
is important because we're going to end
it with his
questions. If you're if you're not
paying attention to scripture, you won't
see how history repeats itself. How
things happening to one person happens
to another. Let me give you one example
that's going to blow you away. In
Genesis 12, it says, "A famine broke out
in the land of Canaan, forcing Abraham
and Sarai to go to Egypt for food. Once
there, the Pharaoh oppressed Abraham by
taking Sarai into his tent or into his
abode so he can have sex with her." It
says God brought plagues plagues upon
Pharaoh and his household, forcing
Pharaoh to release Sarai before he could
then defile her. said, "She's a crazy
woman. Get her out of here." And he sent
out Abraham with great plunder. Sound
familiar? Did that sound familiar or no?
Yeah. You sure? I don't think you got
it. Abraham went into Egypt. The Pharaoh
oppressed him. God brought him out with
a mighty hand by bringing plagues on the
Egyptians, forcing the Pharaoh to
release him with great plunder. That's
what happened to Abraham's descendants.
Oh, okay. See, you didn't get it. You
pretended you got it. See? No, I get it
this time, though. Yeah, that makes
sense. Didn't that is that not what
happened with his descendants? Yes. They
went into Egypt because of famine.
There was famine in the land of Canaan.
And the only way to get food was to go
to Egypt. Yeah. And didn't the Holy
Family settle in Gan in Egypt? Yes, they
did. And the Pharaoh pressed the
Israelites. And then God brought them
out by bringing plagues upon Pharaoh.
And then they came out with great
plunder. Yeah. So what Abraham
experienced, the nation experienced.
Yeah. Another example, if you read
Genesis 20, it says Aimilec, the king of
Girar, took Sarai or Sarah at this time,
so he can sleep with her. And then God
appeared to him and said, "You're as
good as a dead man." Forcing Aimilec to
release Sarah back to Abraham. Right.
Yeah. But hold on. If you read later on
the narrative, it says, "Isaac and
Rebecca were in Girar. And another king
named Aibc also desired Rebecca and
wanted to have her as his wife until he
saw Isaac following her because Isaac,
like Abraham, had said, "She's my
sister?" Yeah. So, wait, you mean two
kings with the same name, Aimilec, in
the same
area, lusted after Abraham's wife and
Isaac's wife? Because both Abraham Isaac
said that their wives are their sisters.
History repeating itself.
Yeah, I think repeated. Yep. You catch.
Okay. Now, how does this tie in with
Israel and Jesus? Well, in Isaiah 49:es
1-6, in Isaiah 49 verse 1-6, one of the
names of the Messiah is
Israel. You know this, right? Or you
don't know this, have you? I do. All
right. So, notice he's called Israel
like he's called David. That tells you
if he's called Israel, he's called
Israel for a reason. Because he's going
to succeed where the nation failed, he
will undo the failure of the nation. The
nation failed, this Israel will succeed,
right? Yeah. Okay. Now, some of the
themes, how many years did the
Israelites spend in the desert? 40
years, right? Yeah. Why 40 years?
Because it took the 12 spies to scout
the land of Canaan, it took them 40
days, right? Yes. Yes. And in Numbers
13, write these verses down. Numbers
13:es
31-33. Numbers 13 31-33. When they came
back and told them, look, the land is
flowing with milk and honey, but there
are giants and aim that makes people
look like grasshoppers.
Okay? 10 of the 12 spies caused the
people to be afraid. So they didn't want
to go. Caleb and Joshua says, "Don't be
afraid. God will deliver them into our
hands. But they refused to go because
they were scared." Then in Numbers 14
33-34, God says, "Here's your
punishment. Here's your punishment. Each
day it took the spies to scout the land.
You're going to remain a year in the
desert so that the first generation will
die and your children will enter. but
not you as your punishment. Wow. So each
day it took them to scout the land. This
is numbers 14 33 34. You're going to
remain in the desert for a year. So it
took them 40 days. So how many years?
40 days or 40 years. So they remain 40
years because God said you your that
first generation, you're all going to
die in the desert. None of you going to
enter except Joshua and Caleb. Your
children will enter, not you because of
your disbelief. So you notice a day
equals a year, right? Yeah. So, Israel
entered the desert to be tested by God
for 40 years and they failed, right?
Yeah. But then Jesus entered the desert
for 40 days and he succeeded. Yeah, he
did. Coincidence?
No. Why did he go into the wilderness?
Uh, it was to be tempted by the by
Satan. You didn't catch it then. Why did
he go into the wilderness for 40 days?
is to reflect the what happened in the
past with numbers with Israel. Israel,
God's son, spent 40 years in the desert
to be trained by God to depend on him
and they failed. God's true son, Jesus,
went into the desert for 40 days and
succeeded.
Okay? In fact, go to Matthew 44.
No. Yeah, Dennis, you're not paying
attention. Pay attention. Matthew 4 1.
Okay. Matthew chapter 4:es 1 and4. Then
Jesus was led up by the spirit into the
wilderness to be tempted by the devil.
And after he had fasted for 40 days and
40 nights, he then became hungry. And
then uh and the tempter came and said to
him, "If you are the son of God, command
that these stones become bread." But he
answered and said, "It is written, man
shall not live on bread alone, but in
every word that comes out of the mouth
of God." Did you see what he quotes in
Matthew 4:4? quoted, "Man shall not live
on bread alone, but on every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God." Right?
Yeah. Don't forget that quote because
I'm going to show you where he quoted
from. Go to Deuteronomy 8. Deuteronomy
chapter 8 verses 1-5 and pay attention
to verse three. Deuteronomy 8:es 1-5.
Okay. Jeremy chapter 8 was verses 1 to5.
But Jesus quotes verse three and see
why. Read Deuteronomy 8:es 1-5. All the
commandments that I am commanding you
today, you shall be careful to do so
that you may live and increase and go in
and take possession of the land which
the Lord swore to give to your
forefathers. And you shall remember all
the way which the Lord your God has
helped you in the wilderness these 40
years in order to humble you, putting
you to the test to know what was in your
heart, whether you would keep his
commandments or not. And he humbled you
and let you go hungry and fed you with
the mana which you did not know nor did
your fathers know in order to make you
understand that man shall not live by
bread alone but man shall live on
everything that comes out of the mouth
of the Lord. Who quoted that?
Uh Jesus quoted it. So is it a
coincidence Jesus quoted Deuteronomy 8:3
in the same context of being in the
wilderness so that he can learn as a man
to depend on God? No, it's not. Now,
notice why God brought them into the
wilderness for 40
years. Look why. Read four and five.
Uh, your clothing did not wear out on
you, nor did your foot swell these 40
years. So, you are to know in your heart
that the Lord your God was disciplining
you, just as a man disciplines his son.
Wait, God was treating them as a son and
taking his son into the wilderness to
discipline and train them to be a good
son. Yeah. And who is Jesus?
Jesus is the son of God. And he too was
taken into the wilderness for 40 days,
which is equivalent to Israel's 40 years
to be trained up and disciplined by the
father to succeed in his mission and
overcome adversities. So, Israel, God's
son, went into the desert 40 years to be
trained and disciplined to learn to be
an obedient son, but they failed. Jesus,
God's true son, true Israel, went into
the desert wilderness 40 days and
succeeded. Amen. You see why he's
quoting Deuteronomy 83? Yes. So,
similarly, if Israel went into Egypt,
then Jesus, true Israel, it's not a
coincidence, he too went into Egypt. So,
you see what Matthew's seeing this? Wow.
the things that happened to the nations
happening to Jesus because he's true
Israel. So these verses about the nation
apply even more so to Jesus because he
is
recapitulating living out Israel's past
experiences so that where they failed he
overcomes and succeeds. Yeah. Are you
catching it? But now let me show you how
Hosea then this principle that the
nation is experiencing and undergoing
events that are a picture of Jesus who's
true Israel. Right. Yeah. Now go to
Hosea 6 2:3. I'm going to show you some
more stuff to blow you away. Just be
patient. Hosea 6:es 2 to3. He will
revive us after two days. He will raise
us up on the third day that we may live
before him. You didn't read two. Read
two and three again. Oh yeah. He He will
revive us after two days. He will raise
us up. I'm sorry. I meant to say 61 and
two. That's my my my mistake. Say 612. I
apologize, sir. You can headbutt me next
time.
Come uh come let's return to the Lord
for he has torn us but he will heal us.
He has wounded us but he will bandage
us. He will revive us after two days. He
will raise us up on the third day. So
when will they be re raised to life?
Only verse two. When will they be raised
up to life to live before the Lord after
God punishes them and puts them to
death? Third day. Third day. Right. So,
the nation will be raised to life on the
third day, right? Yeah. But where will
they be raised from? Go to Hosea
13:14. Hosea
13:14. I hope you guys are paying
attention to this cuz I got a lot more
deep meat to show you. Shall I ransom
them for from the power of sh? Shall I
redeem them from death? Death, where are
your thorns? Sh, where is your sting?
Compassion. Before you do that, God is
going to ransom them out of sh out of
the realm of the dead
and destroy the power of death over
them. Yes. You sure? Yep. Okay. So, God
said that he would raise the nation
spiritually alive, resurrect them to
spiritual life after tearing them and
causing them spiritual death on the
third day. And he raised them out of
shol from the realm of the dead. Right.
Yes. And yet Jesus, God's son, died and
was raised back to life on the third day
from sh.
Amen. You caught it or no? Yes. Yes, I
did. Amen.
See that? Huh? Yeah. Okay. So, so there
you see how the
nation
is prefiguring events in the life of
Christ because like the nation Jesus
went into Egypt. Like the nation, he
went into the wilderness. Like the
nation who would be torn torn to pieces,
caused to die, but then resurrected to
spiritual life on the third day. Jesus's
son was put to death and raised to life
on the third day, destroying the power
of death, the grave, and the nether
world, right? Yeah. Is that a
coincidence? No, it's not. So, you see
why Matthew is quoting things about
Israel, applying it to Christ, because
he's seeing the pattern. Israel is a
picture of Christ. They experienced
things that Jesus also experienced. And
the reason why he's experiencing them is
to relive these events of Israel with
one difference. They failed in these
events. He succeeds. Okay. Now, before
you ask me another question because I'm
going to continue on this theme. Let me
show you how now even Joseph becomes a
picture of Jesus in Genesis 37:9. You
know, well, go ahead. Uh, well, no, no.
Genesis 37:19.
37:19.
Read it for me. What did they call
Joseph?
Uh, they said to one another, "Here
comes this dreamer." So, how did God
speak to Joseph? Through dreams, right?
And visions. Yes. And his father's name
is Jacob, right? Yes. Okay. Now, his
brothers hated him and they then put him
in a waterless pit. Genesis 37:24.
Yeah. Read it. Genesis 37:24.
And they took him and threw him into the
pit. Now the pit was empty without any
water in it. Now remember, it's a
waterless pit because you're going to
remember why this is important. So
Joseph, a dreamer whom God would speak
in dreams and visions. His father's name
is Jacob. His brothers hated him because
they're envious out of him. So they
buried him in a waterless pit. Notice
he's buried in a waterless pit. Yeah.
And then the brothers handed him over to
the
Gentiles, Midionites, IshRaelites, who
then sold him into slavery, who was in
prison. So they handed him over to the
Gentiles who persecuted him. Pay
attention where I'm going with this.
Then Joseph was exalted to become the
Lord of the earth, second to Pharaoh,
and the savior of the world, because he
saved the world from famine, from death.
Right. Yeah. Then his brothers came to
him the first time did not recognize
him. But at the second visit visit he
made his identity known to them. Right?
Yeah. So now notice the pattern. Joseph
hated by his brothers, son of Jacob, who
received revelations from God in a
dream, buried in a waterless pit, handed
over to the Gentiles by his brothers for
20 pieces of
silver, and then exalted by God to be
the Lord of the earth, second to
Pharaoh, and the savior of the world.
And when did he begin saving the world?
When did his ministry begin? Read for
us. If you can go to Genesis 41, read
46. How old was Joseph when he began his
work of salvation?
Now, Joseph was 30 years old when he
stood in the presence of Pharaoh, king
of Egypt. And Joseph went out from the
presence of Pharaoh and went through all
the land of Egypt. When did he begin his
ministry of saving the world and being
the lord of the earth second to Pharaoh?
Yeah. 30 years old. In Luke 3:23, we're
told that Jesus was around 30 years old
when he began his ministry of saving the
world, right? Oh, yeah. Luke 3:23,
right? Yeah. But now, let me show you
the connection with Jesus. Joseph, son
of Jacob, God speaks to him in dreams,
right? And then that's the same Joseph
who brought Jacob into Egypt to save him
from death, right? Yeah. Now go to
Matthew 1:16.
Jacob fathered Joseph, the husband of
Mary, by whom Jesus was born, who is
called the Messiah. So wait, Joseph, the
illegal father of Jesus, is the son of
Jacob. And this Joseph also receives
revelations in dreams. Matthew 1:20. How
did the angel appear to this Joseph?
But when he had thought the when he had
thought this over, behold, an angel of
the Lord appeared to him in a dream,
saying, "Joseph, son of David, do not be
afraid to take Mary as your wife, for
the child who has been conceived in her
is of the Holy Spirit." Two Josephs,
both sons of Jacob, both receive
revelation in dreams. Now, that Joseph
of the Old Testament brought Jacob,
Israel, into Egypt to save his life,
right? Yeah. But this Joseph betrod to
Mary brought Jesus who's also Israel
into a Egypt to save his life. Correct?
Yes. Are you seeing the connections
here? Yes. But then the Joseph that was
a picture of Joseph Mary's betro ends up
becoming a picture of Christ. How? So he
goes from being a picture of Joseph the
legal father of David to being a picture
of Jesus. Like Jesus, Joseph was
betrayed by his brothers, sold for 20
pieces of silver, where Jesus was
betrayed for 30 pieces of silver. Like
Jesus, he was handed over to the
Gentiles who persecuted him. Like Jesus,
he began his ministry of saving the
world at the age of 30. Like Jesus, he
is the Lord of the world, the Lord of
the earth, the savior of the world. Like
Jesus, he was buried in a waterless pit
and God saved him out of that pit. Why
do I say waterless pit? Because the
Bible describes death when you die and
you're not saved as being contained in a
waterless pit. Go to Zechariah 9:es 9 to
11.
Zechariah 9 verses 9 to 11. 9 to
11. Rejoice greatly daughter of Zion.
Shout and triumph daughter of Jerusalem.
Behold your king is coming to you. He is
righteous and endowed with salvation,
humble and mounted on a donkey, even on
a colt, uh the fowl of a of a donkey.
And I will eliminate the chariot of
Ephraim, and the horse uh from
Jerusalem, and the uh bow of war will be
eliminated, and he will speak peace to
the nations, and his dominion will be
from sea to sea, and from the Euphrates
River to the ends of the earth. As for
you also, because of my Because of the
blood of my covenant with you, I have
set your prisoners free from the
waterless pit. You caught it. The blood
of Jesus's covenant sets us free from
the waterless pit. Yeah. Joseph was
buried in a waterless pit and raised out
of it. Right. Yes. So Jesus was buried
and would have descended to what we call
the waters pit, not to be tortured, but
to proclaim victory. And he came out of
that waterless pit. So you see the
simarities. Joseph like Jesus buried in
a waterless pit. Joseph like Jesus
raised out of that waterless pit. Joseph
like Jesus betrayed by his brothers who
hated him and sold for 20 pieces of
silver which Jesus was 30 pieces of
silver. Joseph like Jesus was handed
over the Gentiles to be persecuted.
Joseph like Jesus became the Lord of the
world, the savior of the earth. Lord of
the earth, savior of the world. And
Joseph like Jesus was not recognized by
his brothers at the first visit but were
recognized was recognized at the second
visit. Go to Acts 7:12-13 because when
Jesus returns that's when his brothers
will recognize who he is and who he has
been all along. Acts
7:12-13. But when Jacob heard that there
was uh grain in Egypt, he sent out uh he
sent our fathers there the first time.
And on the second visit, Joseph made
himself known to his brothers and
Joseph's family was re was revealed to
Pharaoh. Okay. So when did they
recognize this was their brother? The
second is when will the nation of Israel
that survives when Jesus is returned
physically bodily to the earth recognize
this is their savior, their Messiah,
their God? Second visit. Coincidence?
Wow. No, that's a